MATTHEW: Our guest today
is Gavin Newsom.
He is the Lieutenant Governor
of State of California and
also the Former Mayor of San
Francisco for seven years.
He's always been a longtime
champion of
innovation and civics.
And also in, I think, social
development, especially
famously being, when he was
mayor, advocating for same sex
marriage for a while, even
though it's against the law.
Which is why--
GAVIN NEWSOM: You don't have
to remind people of that.
MATTHEW: [INAUDIBLE].
What you may not know about
Gavin is that he also brought
universal health care to the
city of San Francisco.
And also, he's been twice
awarded the Most Greenest
Mayor in America, which
is a big deal.
GAVIN NEWSOM: Thanks.
MATTHEW: But we'll here to talk
about "Citizenville,"
which is his book that
just came out.
And basically, I want to start
off-- we actually met before
when you were in the process
of putting together the
background on this.
And what actually brought
you to write this book?
Why did you feel the need
to bring technology and
government together?
GAVIN NEWSOM: Well, frustration,
my own
experiences, the reality that
California, in particular,
when it comes to technology
and governing is on the
leading and cutting
edge of 1973.
And by the way, I literally am
not exaggerating that and I'll
amplify that point
in a moment.
But also, my own experience
using the tools of technology
relatively well to get elected,
to amplify people's
voices, to democratize a
conversation, to engage in a
two-way conversation, to get
you to show up and not only
vote but volunteer,
write a check.
And then when the election
was over, we'd
turn off those voices.
And we'd broadcast for four
years, whereas Matthew and I
were just saying, three, three
and a half until the election
starts over again, and
then we engage you.
My own experience reflecting
on the extraordinary 2008
Obama campaign.
The My Barack Obama effort.
35,000 self-organizing
communities coming together
and this remarkable opportunity
to, as the
president said, not just
change the players in
Washington, DC, but to
change the game.
And his effort to continue to
engage those communities
infamously through a platform
called change.gov.
And he engaged folks famously
or infamously in a
conversation that didn't end so
well from the president's
perspective.
He invited people, these
communities, to come together,
to continue to have their voices
heard and participate
in now governing not
just campaigning.
He created this framework and
encouraged people to say
what's on their mind.
What's your number 1, 2, 3, 4
issues first 100 days of my
administration?
Is it the war in Iraq?
It's the war in Afghanistan, war
on terror, climate change
issues, the financial
meltdown.
What's on your mind?
And just as Michelle Obama did
two weeks ago at the Academy
Awards, he came out in a town
hall with people physically
there and virtually there
and-- envelope, please--
unveiled the number one priority
on people's minds in
the United States of America in
2008, just days before the
transition was complete.
And what was it?
MATTHEW: Legalize pot.
GAVIN NEWSOM: Legalizing
marijuana.
And the president
infamously was--
well, he had a flippant
response.
And the online community
did not take well to
that flippant response.
And as a consequence--
Google it--
see what happened
to change.gov.
It went back for
reconstruction.
It ultimately was transitioned
to the White House website.
The point being it's not easy
to engage in that two-way
conversation because it might
not necessarily go in a
direction that you
want it to go.
And so this book is really about
an exploration to bridge
that gap and to begin to address
the issue of governing
effectively with technology
and having two-way
conversations with citizens
and engaging in active
citizenship as opposed to
citizenship that, from my
perspective, exists today where
we, frankly, treat you
as subjects.
Where we do things to you,
but we don't necessarily
do things with you.
MATTHEW: That's a good theme.
I think we talked before about
everyday democracy.
And after the election's
over, both the
electorate is kind of exhausted.
I think we all were after this
last one, as well as the
politicians when they go back
to their job and actually
getting things done.
However, that seems like
an old-fashioned model.
So how do we have everyday
democracy?
People are very busy and only
the extremists on both sides
will really take active voice
and get involved.
And what kind of tools or ways
can we work to bring people in
an everyday basis, to get their
opinions brought in, in
a constructive way though,
so we're not
just ranting and just--
the town hall, for example, as a
metaphor is maybe a bad one.
When you think about town halls
usually, some radical--
you've been to lots
of town halls.
And so you get the person who
wants to come up to the
microphone and just complain
about this or that.
It's not always the most
important issue of the day.
GAVIN NEWSOM: And that's the
king of the hill concern.
And that's what happened
frankly, with change.gov.
The loudest voices organized
and won.
Marijuana being the
dominant issue.
What about the other issues that
the president rightfully
noted were significant
as well?
And you see that in the physical
world in town halls
that we have all the time where
we claim that's real
engagement.
And we have a budget town hall
where-- truly, I just come
from my experience as mayor
where we had $6.--
almost $7 billion budgets, Of
which the entire debate for
two or three months was around
$20, $25 million.
So talk about a budget that's
baked before we
reach out to you.
That's 99.9% of the budget's
already been done and we're
having a big debate
about 0.1%.
And that's public outreach.
That's participatory budgeting
as we know it.
And who shows up at those town
halls if you have the time?
Usually, the persuasion
industry.
The special interest, folks
with stickers, literally,
would take over those
town halls.
And if you've been to them, you
sit in the back and you
go, I got to get out of here.
I can't participate in this.
And so how do we create a
framework where we can have
civil civic engagement?
And how can we use these tools
and technology to create that
platform of engagement
differently?
And that's what I begin to
explore in this book as I
physically and virtually
traveled across this country
in cities and towns large and
small and looked at what
particularly mayors were doing,
city administrators,
and local government
was doing.
Because I've come to conclude
this, my bias being
self-evident coming from local
government, now of course in
state government.
But my by still remains local.
If you don't like the way the
world looks when you're
standing up, stand on your
head and go local.
You'll see remarkable things
happening at the local level.
One thing I think you all will
agree is proximity confers
some legitimacy.
And we tend to view local
government as a little bit
more responsive.
We may be driven to frustration
by our local
elected officials, but they
tend to be a little more
responsive than state and
certainly federal officials.
And a little less ideological.
I said this long as mayor and
as a candidate for mayor.
Mayors make lousy ideologues
and ideologues
make terrible mayors.
But boy, you go to the federal
level, there's a Republican
plan for Social Security reform
and a Democratic plan
for Social Security reform.
State level, there's an economic
development plan
coming from the Democratic
Party and an economic
development plan coming from
the Republican Party.
If I, as mayor, came out with a
Democratic plan for graffiti
removal, people would roll their
eyes and say, what the
heck's this guy talking about?
Just clean up the damn
graffiti, mayor.
Get it done.
So there is more of an
orientation of results and
less tribalism.
And so local government tends,
from my perspective, to be the
most effective of all forms of
governance as it relates to
solutions and an
entrepreneurial
framework of thinking.
And therein lies some
of the answers
to Matthew's questions.
And in the book, we lay out
some very specific and
promising examples of where
this kind of Socratic
engagement is happening where
those extreme voices are
becoming less and
less relevant.
MATTHEW: One of the things you
have is about the role of data
in all this, and how that's one
of the key-- you use the
word "absolute transparency,"
which is a pretty big
statement, absolute anything
in politics.
And you did caveat that a little
bit by saying, because
there's obviously
privacy issues.
There's issues of security.
And you also talk about
WikiLeaks a little bit as
being an example.
There are some outside
limitations, implications to
absolute transparency.
We were just talking about
that briefly before.
So how do we do this properly?
How do we say everything
should be transparent?
All data should be out there?
Because you know, as you
mentioned over and over, it's
true, that the bureaucrats will
always withhold data.
There's no reason to
get that out there.
You only get skewered
by the press.
You lay yourself out to be
attacked and we don't have an
environment that is
very promising or
conducive to that.
GAVIN NEWSOM: Well,
our default--
and this is a great struggle.
And I don't have the perfect
answer because I don't think
it exists on the issue of
privacy and transparency.
But one thing I do have is a
little bit experience and that
is the default for elected
officials and government
officials is secrecy, period.
Just look at the debate we're
having, literally raging
today, in the wee hours last
night in a filibuster over
John Brennan's confirmation and
Paul arguing around the
drone policy.
And the quote unquote, "memos" a
lack of transparency are the
same relating to the ready,
fire, aim kill list policy and
the due process concerns
around drone strikes of
American citizens that are
legitimate concerns.
Even the most quote unquote,
"self-declared or
self-described" transparent
president, the most
transparent in our history,
President Obama, is still
struggling with this idea of
transparency as it relates to
legal justification of
these drone strikes.
So this is easy to orient
around your rhetoric.
It's difficult to practice
in reality.
My experience has,
interestingly, come right back
here to Google.
And in the book, I talk about
some of the early work we were
doing on Wi-Fi together that
didn't necessarily work out,
free Wi-Fi in San Francisco.
And some of the correspondence
I had with your two founders,
Larry and Sergey, and the emails
that the press got
their hands on through the
Freedom of Information Act.
And they put, literally,
infamously, two-page bleeding
story, front page, screaming
headline in the "San Francisco
Chronicle" with actual photos
of the copies of the email
about absolutely nothing.
But you look at it and you go,
my gosh, some big scandal
between Google and the city.
And there literally was nothing,
but it was a fury of
wanting to get that information
and access that
created this desire.
And my response was, well, I'm
getting rid of my email.
And I literally no longer
emailed anyone after that
because it was a
got you frame.
The press wanted to do
it to play gotcha.
And that's the frame that makes
us less willing to give
information up except
the basic minimum.
I'm not saying that's the right
thing, and I encourage
the press to continue
to do that.
But my argument in this
book is we're living
in a world of WikiLeaks.
We're living in a glass
neighborhood.
You understand this better than
anybody as it relates to
the issues of privacy.
And we're going to have to, if
we're going to build trust
with the public, have to have
a default of openness.
And data is profound from my
perspective in this context.
It's not just about a mayor's
schedule or an elected
official's contacts.
And that's trivial.
That's the "US Weekly" version
of transparency.
That's just pure interest.
It's the substance that's
happening in government
agencies, locally at your
recreation and parks
department, the library system,
state-wide at the DMV,
or big planning commissions,
what's happening federally in
large agencies at Health
and Human Services.
And for us to bring that data
to the light of day in a
machine-readable downloadable
way,
remarkable things can happen.
And that's what is taking shape
across this country as
this open data movement's
beginning to form.
And I was, as mayor,
one of the first--
I think I was the first
mayor in the country--
to establish an open data
requirement for data sets.
And within literally hours of
putting these up, we had apps
that were created by third-party
developers that we
could have never imagined as
government officials the
importance of putting together
that cost us nothing.
Crime data we put out
and all of a sudden
these crime maps occurred.
Transit data and all these
remarkable transit apps.
And we literally created an app
store for not the Android
platform, but in this case for
our own city services.
And we started working with
other mayors across the
country through open APIs
and others to begin
to do the same thing.
And it started making
me think, wow, what
else can we put up?
And what else can the private
sector mash up and see things
that we never could see?
And of course, afford things we
never could afford through
the traditional multi-year
procurement process.
MATTHEW: You bring a lot of
good examples of people,
actually individuals, taking
this data and putting it to
good use, like crime statistics
or homeless
statistics, t hat
sort of thing.
Why is there not more of
a for-profit ecosystem?
You mentioned the [INAUDIBLE]
idea about creating an incubator
for businesses that
take data from the public
sources and make
businesses around it.
Because it seems like there's
lots of people doing
experiments.
There lots of not-for-profit
work.
But to do things at scale and
sustain itself, it seems like
there needs to be more
for-profit models around it.
GAVIN NEWSOM: And I think you're
starting to see that.
I mean, you're starting to see,
particularly in the crime
mapping technology, folks are
starting to scale that and
basically sell out that
technology, the more premium,
the freemium models in other
cities across the country.
So I think you're
just starting to
see this take shape.
But it's the quality
of the data.
I mean, we're still scraping
that data.
We're not providing
all that raw data.
We're still curating it.
And my argument is we need to
do what, interestingly,
President Reagan did in the
'80s with satellite
technology, of which this
company in particular has been
the lion share beneficiary of
monetizing that data, which
used to just be ours.
It used to be meaning
yours as taxpayers.
But it was held in federal
agencies like NOAA.
And that data was just held
there in the vaults, until in
the '80s they decided to open
up that platform and gave us
AccuWeather, gave us Google
Maps, gave us GPS, and all of
these wonderful things.
And millions of jobs have been
created, billions of wealth
have been created because of
that open data effort.
What else is sitting in the
vaults of government that you
can mash up, monetize,
and re-imagine?
And it's limitless the things
that have been stored for
decades, for a century in
governments large and small
all across, not only California
but across this country.
And so that's what
I'm arguing for.
It's difficult though, because
we hold off the issues of
privacy as it relates
being unwilling to
provide certain data.
Again, the default.
And that's our struggle,
is what's appropriate?
It's not personnel
files, per se.
But it's certainly everyone's
salary.
You have a right to know that.
We're struggling with that.
People don't want to necessarily
know that you know
their salary behind the
counter at the DMV.
But they're public servants
and it seems you
have a right to know.
But do you have a right to
know their disciplinary
records or their performance
reviews?
And therein lies
that friction.
And so that's what we're
all struggling with.
MATTHEW: Sure.
I think, actually from a Google
perspective, we're
trying to-- obviously, the data
being made available to
everybody in the world so we can
help make it available to
people, make it useful to
people would be great.
Is there a way of doing this
or going down this path
without sounding like
an ideological idea?
I know you're saying you're not
an ideologue about this.
But to some degree, you're
saying government should get
out the business of doing
some of this.
And basically, get the data
out there and let
other people do it.
And to some degree, we're saying
that means probably the
government's doing less, or can
do other things-- be free
to do other things.
And do we get ourselves caught
in that kind of debate
inadvertently?
It's an issue for us as well
as a company of course.
GAVIN NEWSOM: Brilliant
question.
It's interesting.
A couple years ago I
was re-reading--
in anticipation of the
president's last state of the
union, it's always fun to read
previous states of the union.
Also, it's a great way to
measure success in terms of
promises made and
promises kept.
And a few years ago, the
president had a wonderful--
every year we have
in politics--
politicians are good at this--
we have our themes.
And his was "win the future."
And I remember, this was
three years ago.
He said, you can't win
the future with a
government of the past.
And I'm applauding at least.
And he said, we have 15 agencies
that are responsible
for exports, 5 responsible
for housing policy.
And my favorite, he
says, is salmon.
We have the Department of
Interior that's responsible
for salmon as it relates
to freshwater.
But right when they make their
way out to see, it's the
Department of Commerce
that's responsible
for those same salmon.
We cannot win the future with
a government of the past.
And he was making an argument to
modernize government and to
become more responsive
and effective.
But he then went on to say
something that I thought
rather remarkable for
a Democrat to say.
He quoted Lincoln, this was
before we all started quoting
Lincoln after the movie.
And he said, and I subscribe to
President Lincoln's point
of view that government should
do nothing more than what
individuals can do better
for themselves.
And for a Democrat to say
that, didn't get any
attention, I thought
rather profound.
That's something you would
expect a conservative to say.
And I believe his sincerity
about that in terms of
approaching things like that.
I think now more than ever in
the era of austerity where
we're dealing with, I think, the
three greatest challenges
that will dominate the next 10
years-- the merger of IT and
globalization, the issues of
debt and entitlement, and
energy and climate change and
the impact that will have--
that this is a debate
worth having.
And my framework is the old
Donald Kettl framework, a
political scientist who
made this argument and
observation years ago.
Tim O'Reilly popularized it.
And he's right, the government
today operates more like a
vending machine where you put
in your dollar taxes and you
get limited or finite choices--
police, fire, health
care, education, national
offense.
And if you don't like
what you get--
you've all done it--
what do we do?
We shake the machine.
We kick the machine.
We protest--
Occupy Movement, Tea Party,
whatever it may be.
And not thinking from that
framework of scarcity any
longer, this machine thinking.
Again, the you vote,
I decide model.
To a framework of the
platform, the
smartphone, the Android.
The idea that you didn't develop
700,000 plus apps for
the Android platform.
You've partnered with
millions of people.
And as a consequence, they've
come up with creative
solutions and ideas that
Google could never--
you guys could never
have imagined.
Why not operate government
accordingly as a platform, a
convener, a coordinator?
A cultivator, sure.
To be, as my friend Eric
[INAUDIBLE] says, "big on what
but small on how." Less
prescriptive on how we
actually program solutions, but
committed nonetheless to
dealing with big issues
like ignorance
and poverty and disease.
And use these tools of
technology that you are
creating in real time to
democratize, amplify, voices.
Because one thing I've learned--
it's the old Bill
Joy's law in Sun Microsystems.
He says, no matter who you are,
no matter how good you
think you are as an
organization, the smartest
people work for someone else.
This idea that none of us are
experts in everything, but all
of us are an expert
in something.
How can we connect to that
remarkable capacity
intelligence that exists in
every single one of you and
network that?
That notion of the wisdom
of the crowd.
How can we, as government,
begin to connect that?
Seven years ago, I couldn't have
imagined we'd be living
in the world we are today with
these tools of technology that
allow that possibility
in a profound way.
Government as a platform.
Not small, not big, not
ideological on the frame that
we've engaged.
But strong?
Sure.
Lean?
Absolutely.
Limited?
Fine.
But strong and impactful in
terms of solving big problems.
MATTHEW: By the way, we have
microphones here in the
audience if you want to
line up for questions.
But I will take some from
the audience as well.
Let me actually challenge
you on one thing.
One of the themes in your
book I thought was
harder to kind of accept.
GAVIN NEWSOM: I'll take some
tea as I think about what
you're going to say.
MATTHEW: So the idea that you
want to bring innovation into
government.
I think it's a great idea of
freeing up data and letting
the outside world kind of play
with it and work with it.
But I think bring innovation
into government seems like a
much harder task.
How to I make government
itself more innovative?
What's the challenge?
There's no alternative, they
have a monopoly on power.
And they are the vending
machine.
They control the box.
How do we do this?
And secondly, you bring up this
idea about needing to
start from scratch.
We can't just incrementally
improve a vending machine,
make a better mechanism.
We need to be much more
fundamental, like moving to
the cloud and that
sort of thing.
Both those things to me feel
like for the government a very
unlikely thing to happen.
GAVIN NEWSOM: I get it.
And trust me, I get it.
And just very quick for what
it's worth, background.
I come from the private sector,
but in a very sort of
physical brick and
mortar world.
Small businesses.
I have about 17 small business,
restaurants, hotels,
and wineries, about 1,000
employees in the state.
And I truly say that not to
impress you, but to press upon
you I've always tried to take
that entrepreneurial energy
into my work as a county
supervisor, as a mayor, and
now lieutenant governor.
And it's extraordinarily
frustrating.
I don't want to be more
business-like.
We're not a business.
But I want to be more iterative
and entrepreneurial.
And I think we should encourage
some enlightened
risk-taking in government.
We are risk adverse.
We're scared to death at
tomorrow's headlines.
And so you're absolutely
right.
It's the right question.
It's the standard operating
procedure.
It's a clay layer
of bureaucracy.
It's a big civil service.
It's a large bureaucratic,
hierarchical, top-down
organization in a world where
those organizations are being
leveled by folks like
yourselves.
I mean, I tried to get this
out on Colbert and failed
miserably, but big
is getting small.
MATTHEW: You are a
good-looking guy.
GAVIN NEWSOM: Oh, well,
that's sweet of you.
Thank you.
But you think about--
I have a chapter "The Armies
of Davids," the slingshot's
not the old slingshot.
It's technology now.
It's tearing down large
institutions.
Let's go back to the
newspaper industry.
And the issues happen
in the media,
generally publishing industry.
What's happened in the
music industry.
It wasn't just Sean Parker and
the radicals and the Metallica
folks upset about that.
All of a sudden Jobs made
a deal and everyone
went, whoa, hold on.
And now, all of a sudden, we're
getting customized song
selections.
We're not buying albums.
You're certainly seeing that--
my old uncle is a stockbroker
talking about the good old days
when everyone had to go
through him with those big
commissions and fees.
And so the contours
of this change--
and Don Tapscott talks a lot
about this, his argument being
the industrial economy is
running out of gas.
And these large hierarchical
institutions are being
flattened by technology.
Well, I make the same argument
in government.
Whether, dare I say this phrase,
we like it or not.
Got me in trouble
on gay marriage.
We've got to own up to that
because we're in a collision
course with the future.
We are still iterating
on yesterday's
technology and platforms.
By the way, I made
the case of '73.
Let me be literal.
California, front page of the
"LA Times" to their credit,
did a big report a few weeks ago
about a technology system
upgrade at DMV.
$208 million.
They already spent more than
half the money and weren't
even a quarter of
the way done.
Just fired HP, I'll say it.
And the director at DMV said we
then are still holding on
and holding hope of hopes--
holding hands--
to keep together a 40-year-old
technology system.
We have a case management system
that is so remarkable
at our court system that in
2004, the Chief Justice to his
credit said, I'm going to
upgrade the system.
Identified $260 million
of your money
to upgrade the system.
It was going to be
done in 2008.
Connect the dots, 58 county
systems to allow access,
aggregate this data.
$260 million.
It's going to be done in 2008.
2009, 2010, someone
says, hey, what's
going on with the system?
Did an audit.
One contractor alone had 100--
I kid you not.
I'm not making this up.
Had 103 change orders.
Had already spent $100 million
on their $33 million
subcontract.
They had already spent half a
billion dollars and the report
came out and said, we can still
complete this project.
Not for the $260 million.
Obviously, not by 2008.
But we think we can get it done
by 2015 for-- get this--
$1.9 billion.
You can't make that up.
Now, I bet only one or two of
you have ever heard of that.
But I bet more than half of you
heard about the scandal in
the California recreation and
parks system about the money
we had when we were closing
down those parks.
And what was that scandal?
We didn't "spend" the
money we had.
And I just gave you an example,
hundreds of millions
of dollars of waste.
Our payroll system,
$371 million.
Contractor fired three
weeks ago.
Upgraded CalPERS system, 49 data
centers consolidated into
one called myCalPERS.
Everyone is wishing to get the
old your CalPERS back.
That was only $226 million
over budget.
You can't make this thing up.
We're still buying
and building.
We're still building, not
even buying IT systems.
And we're patching together
technology that was again, on
the cutting edge 40 years ago.
Meanwhile, everyone's
going to the cloud.
We have all these on-demand
resources.
We're going through multi-year
procurements for half a
million dollar websites where
your niece and nephews who are
12 and 13 over the weekends
are doing them for free.
So it's not just the technology
that I'm arguing for.
It's a mindset.
And part of that is sort of--
and I argue in the book-- the
Eric Ries lean startup
construct.
And you're seeing
some of that.
Todd park, HSS, and others have
been able to successfully
incorporate this.
So it's a long way of answering
your question.
I'm seeing the contours
of this change.
And I'm a little more optimistic
because we don't
have a choice.
We are, literally, running
out the clock on this
old model of delivery.
MATTHEW: I mean, to some
degree this is a
generational thing.
It's definitely a different
mindset.
These are the digital natives
versus the people
who come to it later.
GAVIN NEWSOM: The immigrants,
like me,
learning the language.
MATTHEW: Myself included.
Here we are.
But no, I think it's
interesting.
But also I think scarcity
creates creativity.
And to some degree, the good
side of all this austerity
that the governments around
the world are dealing with
right now is they have
to get creative.
And expectations are growing
very quickly.
Are all these lines going
to line up properly?
Like, we have all the
expectations going very fast.
We have problems going
very fast.
Everything is going
exponential.
From your perspective, do you
think the solutions will
outstrip the needs, or are we
going to have potential issues
of political unrest,
or whatever.
How bad can it get from
your perspective?
GAVIN NEWSOM: Thank you.
I mean, this is why
I wrote the book.
Because there's been a trend
line here, but not necessarily
a [INAUDIBLE].
And when I say collision
course of the
future, I mean it.
You think about just--
I was with Tom Friedman-- and I
reference this in the book--
who wrote "The World is Flat"
in 2005, bestseller.
It talks about his connected
world, issues of globalization
and technology.
It's really a technology book.
And Tom was here
at Santa Clara.
We did an economic development
summit.
And he summed it up
quite brilliantly.
And forgive the examples.
You guys are confident in your
own success of the fact that I
won't mention you should not
diminish your status in
relationship to this because you
were ahead of the curve.
But he made the point in his
book "The World is Flat" in
2005, Facebook wasn't
even in it.
This is a book about technology
and globalization.
In 2005, not that long ago.
He said Twitter was a sound.
The cloud was in the sky.
4G was a parking space.
LinkedIn was a prison.
Apps were things we filled
out to get into Stanford
University.
And Skype, for most
of us, was a typo.
And his point is we're no longer
in a connected world,
but a hyper-connected world.
Those things are ubiquitous, by
definition, in our lives.
As you are in our lives.
And they didn't exist as
we know them seven
or eight years ago.
This trend line is
extraordinary.
And as a complement to your
point, this is a generation,
this net generation, this
digital natives, of choice.
Where everything's being
customized around you.
And we still have mass systems
of education, fast food models
of education, standardized
everything.
We're still professors
to teach--
teacher's professing and giving
you, broadcasting what
you're supposed to
be learning.
We still, my gosh, you sit in
rows of desks based on your
date of manufacture.
Same age cohort, same single
subjects ringing bells that
Ben Franklin would have heard
hundreds of years ago.
And you extend that out.
That's the way we're
educating people.
Extend that out to all
government services.
I mean, you literally
go into the DMV.
I got a text message, I kid
you not, about a renewal.
You can't make this up where
it said a change of address
because I had just moved.
It says, please--
I mean, literally a week
ago, it said type--
the word "type." You've
got to be kidding.
You can type or write in with
ink your change of address on
your card and keep
it with you.
Talk about just completely
antiquated
thinking in every respect.
So I am very fearful because
when we ask you to vote every
two or four years and you've
got to figure out where the
heck to do that down at
some fire station.
It used to be post office,
but we know what's
happening to them.
And then you connect the dot
with this felt-tip pen that
may or may not work because it
was sitting out and no one put
the cap back on.
And then all of a sudden, they
give you a nice sticker.
Meanwhile, you're Googling on
your latest iteration of the
Android platform and you're in
the real world and you're
disconnected.
Meanwhile, you're voting like
and dislike on YouTube 15
times as you were waiting
in line to vote
for the next president.
It's completely antithetical
the world we're living in.
So when I talk about collision
course, I mean it.
And we better wake up because
this is, I think, code red for
government.
LA just had their big mayor's
race two days ago.
And it wasn't just
the mayor's race.
It was their city attorney.
It was tons of ballot
initiatives.
And this is the second
largest city in the
United States of America.
Largest city in California.
Profoundly significant
to the GDP of this
state and our nation.
Major race for mayor.
And a remarkable
thing happened.
They said it was almost record
numbers of people showed up.
Everyone was so pleased.
It broke 15% of registered
voters.
We're talking single
digit folks.
And it's not an indictment of
the previous mayor, but he was
reelected with 158,000 votes in
a city of 4 million people.
And it's nothing
to do with him.
People are just disengaged.
Outside of presidential
campaigns, we just don't care.
And you're solving problems
peer to peer
now more than ever.
You've heard of donor's
choose and you're
saying, you know what?
I'm going to go right
in the classroom
and solve my problems.
I'm not waiting around for guys
like this Newsom guy how
to solve my problems.
I'll go to Kiva.
I'm going to solve problems
in Kenya and hey,
Kiva's now in our back--
I'm going to solve problems in
the Mission District in San
Francisco with kiva.org.
Or, I'm going to go on Indiegogo
or Kickstarter,
whatever it is, to
solve problems.
And so how do we take that
populism that's in the air and
reconnect it with government?
Because I believe
in government.
I want to make a case
for government.
And I want to reconnect your
purpose and passion and make
it fun again.
That's the rift Citizenville.
Games, gamification, and what's
happening in the world.
I remember "Schoolhouse Rock!"
Some of you are old enough to
remember "Schoolhouse
Rock!," right?
MATTHEW: Definitely.
GAVIN NEWSOM: Age of
you and I, buddy.
MATTHEW: Conjunction Junction.
GAVIN NEWSOM: A couple.
But remember we all remember
it because it was fun and
educational.
The only thing--
how a bill becomes a law on
Capitol Hill you may recall.
The only thing they didn't
mention was lobbyists, how it
really works.
Money.
But it was entertaining
and educational.
I mean, you're seeing the
examples of this in the "New
York Times" columnist Kristof
who just did with "Half the
Sky" talking about the
issues of women.
They just came up with social
games for good.
And they have a game to
encourage people and to
educate people about the issue
of women and girls around the
world in empowerment.
And so how do we meet people
where they are?
MATTHEW: Again, let me encourage
people to take the
microphone if they
have questions.
I know you didn't talk about
this much in your book, but I
did want to ask you, how does
this play out internationally?
You talked mostly, it
seemed like, about
domestic politics here.
But what's your view on that?
GAVIN NEWSOM: It plays
perfectly.
[INAUDIBLE]
in Spain, [INAUDIBLE].
I mean when the microbloggers
in China, quarter
of a billion folks.
Chinese government cannot
suppress those voices, even
though they spend more money
in China to suppress voices
than they do on national
defense.
What's happened obviously,
[INAUDIBLE]
Square.
It's happened around the
rest of the world.
It's very real and
very relevant.
And of course, your own Eric
Schmidt coming out with a book
to raise that consciousness and
elevate the international
debate along these same
lines with his book.
MATTHEW: Let's take some
questions from the audience.
MALE SPEAKER: So I just came
back from living a few years
in a rather large city, which I
won't mention to prejudices,
and the trains and subways
are clean.
They run on time.
They're not expensive.
There's no garbage
on the streets.
The potholes are filled,
et cetera, et cetera.
And I come back to San Francisco
and I'm trying to
understand--
GAVIN NEWSOM: It's changed
since I'm mayor, I know.
Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: And the
taxes aren't that
much higher, either.
I'm trying to understand how
what you're talking about is
going to solve those really
basic questions.
Let's forget about the fancier
ones you're talking about.
GAVIN NEWSOM: Well, I
mean, substantively.
I could give you dozens of
examples as it relates to
issues of homelessness,
potholes.
I mean, just one example
see, click, fix.
See a pothole, click it, send
it with the open API we did
with Twitter to 311
call center in San
Francisco, fix it.
Two-way conversation, measured,
mapped, and people
are empowered.
Citizens are more engaged.
And we are held to a higher
level of accountability.
I can give you dozens of
examples of improved
efficiency, reduced costs, more
citizen engagement with
these kinds of tools of
technology that begin to
address the timeliness of buses,
the ability to address
panhandling, the competency of
our efforts to pave and clean
streets along the lines
of your question.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, but that
other one I'm talking about
was put in place by a big
bureaucracy and so
forth and it worked.
And I'm saying there's probably
something a whole lot
more-- and by the way there,
if a train's more than five
minutes late, they give you a
paper so you can give that at
the office because that's
how seldom it happens.
GAVIN NEWSOM: I guess I have
a bias for our form of
governance as imperfect
as it is.
I'm with Justice Brandeis that
in a democracy, the most
important office is the
office of citizen.
And what I'm arguing for here is
active citizen engagement,
which with respect to some of
those examples, though I don't
know yours particularly, I doubt
there's that kind of
active citizen engagement.
There's probably more of a
top-down centralized model of
governance that I don't
necessarily think in the long
run is going to service
more than just
getting trains on time.
It doesn't service the
entrepreneurial passions and
the innovative spirit that I
think defines the best of our
region and our state.
MALE SPEAKER: It was
a democracy.
GAVIN NEWSOM: Yeah.
Well, let me also
just concur--
hell, I was just at the Incheon
Airport in Korea,
which is one of those airports
you just hope along the lines
you're arguing that you have
your plane delayed because
it's got a couple golf courses,
hotel, spa, a museum.
And I flew from there to LAX,
which literally-- you got my
point-- is like flying from
the Jetsons to the
Flintstones.
So I'm not denying your
example and embracing
high-speed rail and the
remarkable capacity in
Singapore and other parts
of the world to
do wonderful things.
We got to get back in
the future business.
That's certainly a big part of
what I talk about every day
and try to connect some
dots in the book.
And I do think there's
ways that we can
substantially compete.
And I'm not giving
up on our form of
governance yet, though.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks for coming
to see us, Gavin.
I think apathy is certainly
one of the huge issues our
government's facing right now.
But recently, the last couple
years since the Citizens
United case, the super PAC
money, or as Colbert would
call it, spooky PAC money,
seems to have--
GAVIN NEWSOM: I contributed to
his Super PAC, by the way.
MALE SPEAKER: Did you?
Good job.
So did I.
GAVIN NEWSOM: I did.
That's why I went on
his show, I think.
I paid for that.
MALE SPEAKER: You
paid for that.
GAVIN NEWSOM: And did I
pay after I went on.
I did "Meet the Press"
two days later.
I was so relaxed.
I'm like, oh, this is great.
MALE SPEAKER: It was easy.
GAVIN NEWSOM: Colbert, jeez.
MALE SPEAKER: Everything's
easy [INAUDIBLE].
GAVIN NEWSOM: I'll warn
Eric before he
goes on his book tour.
I'm just saying.
Eric, if you're listening,
beware.
MALE SPEAKER: So with that
threat still out there, do you
see these new platforms, these
new ways of engagement, as
ways to overcome what's going
on with Citizens United and
Super PACs?
Do we have to be worried about
movements being co-opted?
I think we saw a little bit with
the Tea Party movement
and things like that of
groups coming in.
How do we get around this?
GAVIN NEWSOM: Maybe it's a bit
idealistic, but I think
organized voices are more
powerful than organized money.
I think the participatory nature
of social media, the
ability to engage,
self-organizing like
[INAUDIBLE] communities,
ultimately will empower and
engender a more successful
result than those that
centralize and try to pick
winners and losers with a
Super PAC framework
of engagement.
It's interesting, of all people,
I got this strange--
by definition, for me,
it was strange.
It wasn't a strange email.
But Newt Gingrich reached out
to me, called the book
extraordinary.
I responded in saying, I have
to re-read my book, Newt.
I'll get back to you.
MATTHEW: Did he tweet
about it?
GAVIN NEWSOM: What the
hell was in this?
And I kid you not, I sent him
another email late last night
because he wrote a newsletter
reinforcing that, encouraging
everyone to read this book
because he picked up on
something that goes
to your question.
He's in a big fight-- and he
didn't say this, but I now get
it-- with Karl Rove because he
doesn't like what Rove's
trying to do.
And this is not about the
veracity of either argument,
it's just an interesting
debate.
Because Rove is trying to make
a case that we're going to
pick and choose winners in these
states, so that they're
more electable so we can take
back the Senate in 2014.
And Gingrich is fiercely
fighting that because he
believes that's a centralized
top-down frame where big money
is trying to influence
elections.
And his argument is bottom-up
thinking, which is my argument.
His argument is small-town
conservatism.
His argument is grass roots.
And I find that interesting.
And he was able to connect the
dots here on technology in
looking at a 21st century form
of governing and organizing in
relationship to what he would
call those Jeffersonian
principles of individual liberty
and self-government.
And so it goes back to your
question earlier, which is an
interesting one, that there's
sort of an ideological
bandwidth here that's a lot
broader than what you'd expect
coming from an ex-mayor of San
Francisco and a Democratic
lieutenant governor from
one of the bluest
states in our nation.
MATTHEW: It goes to what you
said about change.gov as well,
which is it's very difficult
to get these
tools right, initially.
I think we collectively had
some first missteps that I
think we'll learn from.
But the tools have
to be smarter.
And they have to weed out, I
guess, the spammers and people
who are misguiding it or
try and co-opt it.
And we have a lot of experience
with this as
company I think with communities
that we have to
curate and work with YouTube
and so forth.
I think a lot of that will have
to work in the political
sphere, too.
Otherwise, it could
be co-opted.
GAVIN NEWSOM: Yeah,
that's true.
MALE SPEAKER: I don't know if
you are familiar in the last
elections in November, there
was a young 18-year-old who
ran for mayor of Fremont.
He's my son, by the way.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: And he ran on the
platform of something just
along the lines of what
you're talking about.
He wanted to bring about
transformational change in the
government.
And how the government should
start thinking out of the box
and bring about innovative
solutions in how to govern.
And obviously, he didn't win.
But he still has a passion
and he has the energy.
What advice would you have for
young people like him to join
politics, and how do they
bring about change?
GAVIN NEWSOM: I love it.
Thank you, and congrats.
And you're obviously a good role
model that you encouraged
him to do it at a
remarkable age.
Two thoughts on this.
First thing is you're absolutely
right, I'm arguing
for a different division
of labor.
I'm not arguing for
e-government.
That's happening
on the natural.
And I hate this phrase, but
I'll use it because it
simplifies it, I'm arguing
for we government.
I want more voices
and more choices.
I want to devolve and
involve people into
building sense of community.
I support real participatory
budgeting along the lines of
what Brazil's been doing.
New York just started a
small version of this.
Real, active citizen engagement,
not inert
citizenship.
So that's the argument.
But I also make an argument
in this book--
and this is my advice to your
son, that this is a book about
leadership.
And I make the case that--
and this is my belief.
Good people can disagree.
That we've got it wrong holding
it out for this guy or
gal on the white horse to come
in and save our day.
I don't buy that anymore.
My father years and years ago
used to make this point and it
came together when Tom Peters
wrote about this years ago,
and he really distilled it.
What did Dr. King, Gandhi,
Mandela, and Havel all have in
common at the peak of
their influence?
Havel, King, Mandela, Gandhi,
the peak of their influence,
what did they have in common?
Jail time.
Interesting fact.
But they also had something
else in common.
They exercised their
moral authority.
None of them had formal
authority.
In fact, you could argue that
when Vaclav Havel--
in fact, he argued himself in
a lot of his writings--
became president of
Czechoslovakia, he lost a lot
of his influence.
Same with Mandela after getting
formal authority in
South Africa.
And so my advice to your son
is to consider that.
You don't need to be--
MATTHEW: Go to prison?
GAVIN NEWSOM: No.
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW: OK, just being clear.
GAVIN NEWSOM: The moral
component of that.
But if he must, he must.
We sure as heck risked it
as you said when we
broke the law in 2004.
I thought I'd be recalled
and arrested.
I really did.
Was willing to do that to put
a human face on an issue of
something I cared about because
I didn't want to wait
30 years, as was the case with
interracial marriage, to one
day see it happen
in my lifetime.
Here we are nine years later
and we may see it in a few
weeks at the Supreme Court.
That said, to consider that you
don't need to be something
to do something.
You don't need to be somebody
Exercise your moral authority.
And make the determination of
whether or not being part of
the system is actually better
than being outside the system.
Maybe it's good he
lost is my point.
Final point, back
to the we always
are now quoting Lincoln.
The one quote I never hear of
Lincoln that I love says we're
all born originals but
we die copies.
And I think of that in the
context particularly of
politicians and elections.
We watch those campaign
commercials and you're like,
wow, that guy or gal,
she's great.
So creative.
So passionate.
So authentic.
And then you look back 15
years later when they're
termed out and you say,
man, they just--
what happened to that person?
They're like everybody else.
It's as if the process of
governing de-geniuses you.
The system de-geniuses you.
Originality is lost because of
the way things are done.
Remember, Obama again, let's
not-- he was right and he
struggled with this.
We don't want to change
the players, we want
to change the game.
And that's my argument
in this book.
We've got to redesign, as your
son wanted to redesign, that
engagement.
And redesign our thinking and
consciousness around the role
of government and the role of
citizens in relationship to
our governing institution.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi, Gavin.
I'm wondering how we can
institute a gamification of
the political while still
keeping the rhetoric relevant.
So for every White House
petition for unlocking
cellphones, we have one about
the Death Star and we have one
about R. Kelly's [INAUDIBLE].
GAVIN NEWSOM: You don't feel
the Death Star's important?
MALE SPEAKER: I do, but--
GAVIN NEWSOM: What about
deporting Piers Morgan?
How about daylight
savings latest
petition coming this Sunday?
Good point.
Tim O'Reilly-- we had a great
conversation in this book
about this.
And he made this case, and the
reason I put it in is I agree
with him 100%, that this is
not about creating a new
framework of petitioning
government to
do things for you.
This is about creating new
mechanisms to do things with
government.
This is about creating a new
platform and framework of real
engagement.
President Obama, as you know,
took the change.gov and now
it's done something called
We the People.
And after 5,000 virtual
petitions, Jay Carney at the
White House would respond to
any of those petitions.
And the Death Star was one of
the dominant petitions.
They kind of disregarded that.
The press disregard that.
But the Piers Morgan example
was infamous.
Because right after the NRA went
after Piers, there was a
big petition to deport Piers
back to the country that
forced us to bear arms
in the first place--
those Brits.
And it got 70-plus-thousand.
And there's Carney in the
beginning of the debate around
drones going you've
got to be kidding.
Guy is on CNN and I have
to respond to this?
So what did the White
House decide to do?
They decided to raise the
threshold for petitions before
they respond, missing
the whole point.
It's not about petitioning
folks with the machine
thinking to do things for you.
It's about that again, new
division of labor and
different kind of engagement.
MALE SPEAKER: This is sort of
an ideological question, but
you touched upon this earlier.
Why is the public sector so
inefficient and so averse to
change compared to the
private sector?
GAVIN NEWSOM: Well, it's the
old adage, move the mouse,
move the cheese.
You want to move it, you
got to move the cheese.
There's no incentive
for good behavior.
There's incentive for
terrible behavior.
Every single person's
acting in their best
interest all of the time.
It's a remarkably efficient
thing and it's rather
predictable.
The sequestration is a perfect
example of that.
It's in everyone's interest
to do what they've done.
Otherwise, they wouldn't
do it.
I mean, you think about
Congress in
single digit ratings.
I mean literally, you remember
the debater around NFL
replacement refs?
There was a new poll just came
out that shows three to one
people prefer the NFL
replacement refs to Congress,
which I just think
sums it all up.
But yet, Republican Congress
in single digits won
reelection rather
overwhelmingly.
They only lost eight seats.
I mean, they may seem
significant.
But at the end of the
day, they held
onto a strong majority.
Just two seats in the Senate.
We act in our best interest
because the system's designed
for inefficiency.
We are a monopoly.
The only way you get fired is
actually working outside of
your job description.
The reason I have a failure
award in my businesses, why I
reward the biggest screwup, is
I can't stand the contrast
with my day job as lieutenant
governor in government.
I have a little hotel,
just very, very
briefly up in Tahoe.
A lot of mosquitoes
during the winter.
It was built in 1959 for the
delegates of the Olympics, the
'60 Olympics.
So it's an old hotel.
We don't have air
conditioning.
So we keep the doors to the
hallways open in the summer.
I had one of those
eccentric folks.
They're all eccentric,
those night clerks.
The guy when you check in at
2:00 in the morning you go,
who is this person?
Why would you have this job?
And this guy decided on his own
before he came to work at
11 o'clock at night to buy a
bunch of catfish because he
thought-- it was an
interesting idea.
He said, I'm going to take the
catfish and put it in all the
ponds outside of the hotel so
they after the mosquitoes.
Maybe we'll reduce the problem
we have with mosquitoes.
Well, he leaves about 5:00 in
the morning and Ludo, who had
been with me for--
I don't know, 14, 15 years--
my engineer,
never once called me.
Wakes me up.
Goes, I can't believe this.
I don't know what to say, but
you have to hear this.
It's the strangest thing.
I think we've been vandalized.
But all throughout the hotel--
and It.
Could be worse.
This is strange.
But there's eyeballs of fish.
There's tails.
There's all these fish.
I mean, it's just chaotic.
Bones.
So I'm going call
you right back.
I just need to let
you know this.
I'm like, what the
hell is this?
I said, figure this thing out.
Calls me back a couple hours
later and figured it out.
Our night clerk went out,
bought catfish,
put them in the ponds.
And what happened?
The raccoons got in in total
delirium, wildly enthusiastic,
running around, were running
through the hotel, and
throwing the carcasses all
around, et cetera.
And so I heard this relieved and
was inspired to create the
failure award.
I gave this guy an $800
bonus because it was
such a glorious failure.
And it contrasted so well to my
days in San Francisco as a
supervisor at the time where
the only-- if something
happened like that, that person
would have been fired.
As opposed to celebrating a
glorious failure and learning
from it because the guy
had initiative.
And I'll close with this,
just to underscore.
I'm a big labor guy.
We're a $10.55 minimum
wage city.
We have universal preschool,
not just
universal health care.
Heck, our kindergarten
students.
I created sometime I'm so proud
of called K through 12
where we're giving little
college savings accounts to
every single person that enters
into kindergarten gets
their own online bank account.
It starts small, but it
creates a mindset of
expectation.
The old adage, once a mind's
stretched, it never goes back
to its original form.
We're a pretty progressive
place.
And labor's been sponsored,
all those things.
They've been fabulous.
But there was a big contract
that said performance reviews
and disciplinary records cannot
be considered with
regard to promotion.
I'll repeat that.
The largest public employee in
San Francisco said performance
reviews comma disciplinary
records cannot be considered
with regard to promotion.
Imagine if Google had that?
Hey, that'd be great.
You want to go to Tahoe today?
And I just thought it was
a demoralizing thing.
And I fought to take that out.
And the point was we only
celebrated the success of
someone just being around an
extra few days or months or
years, but not someone's
creativity,
not someone's genius.
And that's the kind of incentive
that's going to
elevate our quality and our
capacity to improve.
And that created that friction,
that stress that
I've had over these years
living in both worlds.
And frankly, what I hope--
long-winded way of wrapping
things up--
that in this book I provide
some specific tangible
examples to begin to address a
hybrid of these two principles
and philosophy so that, in
closing, government can become
as smart as Google.
Thank you, guys.
MATTHEW: Thank you very much.
GAVIN NEWSOM: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]